تقارير المستمره عن العنف عبر خطوط
التماسلسيه ما في الجوف كعاز مارب وسعده
تؤكد على هشاشه الوضع الراهن وعلى ضروره
التوصل الى وقف رسميا لاطلاق النار
ويقلقني كذلك التدهور في الوضع الاقتصادي
والقيود المفروض على حريه الحركه وتاثيرها
على النشاط الاقتصادي وعلى حياه السكان
ومصادر رزقهم ان عدم قدره حكومه اليمن
تصدير النفط الذي يولد اكثر من نصف
العائدات الحكوميه وولد اكثر من نصف
العائدات الحكوميه العام الماضي يقيد قدره
الحكومه على الايفاء بموجباتها ازاء شعب
اليمن وان السياسات الاقتصاديه والماليه
غير المتصقه في مختلف مناطق البلاد القط
بعبئها على المواطنين والشركات والشركات
تعيش اليوم في انعدام يقين في صنعاء وفي
المحافظات المجاوره
غياب التعاون بين الاطراف بشان المسائل
النقديه والماليه الرئيسيه يعني ان هذه
التحديات ستتفاقم وستزداد عمقا بالرغم من
كل هذه التحديات العميقه ثم مجال للتفاؤل
الحذر في الاسابيع الاخيره اعتمد الاطراف
بعض الخطوات الايجابيه الاضافيه وعلى اثر
اطلاق
محتجزا الشهر الماضي بتيسير من المكتب
ولجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر ودعم من
حكومه سويسرا
من المملكه العربيه السعوديه اطلق انصار
الله
مجموعه اضافيه من المحتجزين وانا واثقه من
ان اطلاق سراحي هؤلاء سوف يوفروا بيئه
مؤديه للحوار ولكن مع كل عمليه اطلاق
وفي حين ان هذه تعتبر ايجابيه للموقفين
واسرهم هناك الالاف الذين ما زالوا في
الاحتياجات لذلك ادعوا الاطراف الى
الاستمرار بالعمل مع مكتب للايفاء
بواجباتهم للافراج عن كل المحتجزين وفقا
لاتفاق ستوكه
منذ اسبوعين تماما وفي الثالث من عيار
مايو احتفلنا بالذكرى الثلاثين لليوم
العالمي لحريه الصحافه وفي حين ان الافراج
الاخير عن اربع صحفيين كجزء من اتفاقي
اطلاق سراح المحتجين يعتبر خطوه ايجابيه
ما زال
الناشطون في مجال الاعلام في اليمن
يواجهون التهديد والمضايقه والسجن ومصادره
مكاتبهم وممتلكاتهم ادعوا كل الاطراف
بموجب القانون الدولي الى الافراج عن كل
المحتجزين تعسفيا بما في ذلك الصحفيين
ومناصر حقوق الانسان
والمعرضين السياسيين وكل المدنيين
المحتجزين تعسفيا السيده الرئيسه
ان اساس اي اتفاق حول السبيل قدما يجب ان
يكون استئناف العمليه السياسيه بقياده
يمنيه برعايه الامم المتحده لانهاء النزاع
وحدها عمليه سياسيه شامله وجامعه يمكن ان
توصل الى شراكه سياسيه جديده وان تضمن
مستقبلا امنا ومستقرا اقتصاديا يمكن فيه
لمؤسسات الدوله ان تعمل بفعاليه وان تعود
اليمن الى علاقات سلميه مع جيرانهم هذه
العمليه السياسيه يجب ان تعالج مواضيع
الشائكه على المدى الطويل ويتعين مع ان
تبدا باقرب فرصه ممكنه وان الطابع الجامع
لهذه العمليه جوهري لضمان استدامه اي حل
سياسي
الحوار الذي اجري مؤخرا بين عدد من
المجموعات السياسيه الجنوبيه في عدن يؤكد
مجددا على ضروره ان يناقش اليمنيون جماعيا
مستقبلهم وان يتفقوا عليهم من خلال عمليه
بقياده يمنيه ودعم اممي في هذه العمليه
لابد من سماع صوت كل اليمنيين ونؤكد كذلك
على اهميه مشاركه النساء والشباب في كافه
نواحي عمليه السلام وفقا لقرار مجلس الامن
1325 واشراك المجتمع المدني كذلك ان
المشاركه المجديه والفعاله لا تقتصر فقط
على عدد النساء وممثل المجتمع المدني
المشاركين ولكن انها تشمل كذلك اتاحه حيزا
للنساء والمجتمع المدني لمعالجه اولوياتهم
والمساهمه بخبراتهم ومعارفهم فالمراه
والمجتمع المدني غالبا ما يتم اسكاتهما
السيده الرئيسه اود ان اختنمها فرصه لاعيد
التاكيد عن تقدير للدعم هذا المجلس الثابت
فان عمل مجلس ووحدته حول اليمن امر نرحب
به وان دعمكم المستمر ومرافقتكم لاي اتفاق
يتم التوصل اليه سيكتسب اهميه اكبر ليس
فقط على المدى القصير بل على المدى الطويل
ايضا يعمل اليمن على رسم مستقبل سلميا
وزاهر يستجيب الى طموحات شعب اليمن شكرا
على حسن الاسواق
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات